montrer le vrai jo une aventure d'un
soir m ah si c'est vrai oui mes vacances
moi un seul coup mais bon c'était
l'hiver c'est l'hiver annonces en
fonction pas dans le thème on s'en fout
de la saison et en plus je regrette de
vous dire de pas pouvoir vous dire avec
qui parce que vous rigoleriez non c'est
quoi l'histoire c'est quoi non mais
parce que c'était c'était quelqu'un de
ces scènes on se calme s'il vous plaît
là les mecs là y'a aussi quelqu'un de
connu quelqu'un de connu et je pense que
tout cinéma alors n'attendez pas non
mais c'est tout ce n'est pas juste c'est
que cette personne est encore de cela
dont il va si tu nous regardes de là
haut
non mais tu te dire sartec sarhani tu
l'as dit
cette personne n'est pas décédée des
suites de cette relation
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
après l'italien nadia arrête je veux
dire ici qu'est ce qu'on a dit ce soir
tout ce qui sera dit si m cette émission
avec nos téléspectateurs avec toc fans
je vois là bas si reste des vivants dans
l'histoire on sait combien elles
connaissent bien et s'apprécient rigoler
ils ont fêté le thriller pourquoi lui
maintenant on dit tout de même à noter
si les mauves à zidane et les gens du
tout daniel je suis quelqu'un allait
tous ton avis oui qu'on aimait tout
venant pas du tout beau mec alors là
chapeau mou
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais qu'on arrête là tu parles la
honte autant pas doit tout reprendre
depuis le début on est en quelle année
mme et en quelle année dans les années
80 dans les années 99 cents
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors les dans les années 80 daniel
moreau commence en 1881 non elle ne
reviendrons d'ailleurs 1980 par des
petits larcins vol de renault 18 vols de
weston ou encore vol de banesto très
vite se lancent dans le grand banditisme
et en 1981 elle fait la connaissance de
la top argenté savate illettrés pas beau
mais il était très beaucoup de succès
m alors attention quoi la dbm été bm
vous êtes w vous c'est quoi la bm ne
sais pas encore daniel mot 1980
exactions alors nous sommes en 1981 la
jeune daniel moreau jeune 18 ans elle
avait 18 ans nous sommes dans 1981
daniel moreau et fraîche
cette fraîcheur de vivre dans le métier
après le combat hollywood chewing gum
elle est innocente
oui ah oui à cette époque mais pas pour
longtemps fait la connaissance d'une
personne alors que son corps n'a pas
connu l'amour qu'une envie c'est de
faire connaître cet hommage exactement
cette personne est ce un homme et une
femme
est ce un animal ça personnel c'est la
civi beau daniel moreau il est l'heure
de passer à table
9h45 on apprécie d'ailleurs daniel
moreau
c'était un homme à sa vie vous avez
couché avec lui le premier soir ah ouais
mais en fait non non non timide j'ai
posé dire s'il était tellement célèbres
et j'étais tellement qui viennent manger
j'ai même pas osé
il était tellement célèbre attendez on
tient quelque chose quelque chose une
immanence y tenait quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
et apparemment à demain exactement
est-ce que c'était sa première relation
sexuelle si on peut excuser moi fait
partie de l'anc est entre greffier
intégré n'est pas là pour poser des
questions mais que sa première relation
sexuelle
écoutez ce qu'on vous pose des questions
est ce que c'est votre première relation
sexuelle
ça ne m'était pas c'était un petit un
petit intermède c'est est ce qu'on
appelle un an tu as mal à arrêter là
dernier
sortie
[Applaudissements]
j'ai le titre on a alors daniel ma
chérie tu se dit tous ici mais oui mais
alors on ne te demande pas de nom à on
veut juste savoir cette personne donc
c'était un homme il avait quel âge à
l'époque 60 vont fatah avait 18 ans il
avait 60 ans dis-moi 18,60 on dirait on
dirait des trucs s'il est encore plus
visible avec pas le mur alors donc vous
à il avait 60 ans non non on ne dira pas
même si ces mets ont pourtant fait
savoir c'est un chanteur anac des os je
ne suis que des prémices de loket
19h47 la démission jusqu'à manquera donc
allez vous mener le combat en tunisie ou
au maroc
les enquêtes se font en deux minutes il
est papa donc tu partais pas de quoi
voulez écouter va bien la demoiselle
moreau celle de mademoiselle b toujours
est ce que c'est un chanteur
non un acteur quelqu'un qui nous a
beaucoup fait rire c'est tout ce que
nous avons convié les c'est un humoriste
est un art est oui c'est pas de gaulle
la situation alors est ce que son nom
tenant trois lettres
ah non non non c'est pas si mon nom mais
ça du même acabit
allez les mecs salaires nominaux il
avait 60 ans 80 s'est pas tu comptes
équilibrés savannah est arrêté à louis
ii oui de finale voire comique c'est un
acteur c'est dans le 7 dans le centre
est reconnue n'est pas gai lui-même
reconnu après ça il y en a 10 ans et non
à la bouche mais non
et j'ai même le filet ne dit pas de
bêtise elle resterait aussi dit oui
voilà alors attends vinci mais non mais
comme j'en ai fais tomber la 7ème
compagnie l'appareil mais là c'est fait
tu l'attends pascal hamet ya beaucoup
d'aspects caisse alors je ne voudrais
pas balancer mais la lotte unis pas non
maintenant il est marié je dis pas du
tout le non non je dis simplement que
franck dubosc sait qui c'est passé alors
versé diana on sait que c'est
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vrai j'ai pu faire un bel envol à
la bassée bongo et qu'elle veut faire un
bel enfant en tube à cette histoire est
folle ouais l'édition est folle non mais